come on in he wants to talk new nuclear
and clean energy nuclear is a vital part
of our future but it's Labor's
controversial plan to ban new oil and
gas extraction that has caused criticism
including from the GMB Union it
represents tens of thousands of energy
workers
and today kirstama addressed its annual
conference on my walk good jobs good
union jobs will be fundamental to that
change
some members including from Scotland the
hearts of UK oil and gas seemed
unconvinced Labor's position on blocking
new licenses is a threat to Scottish
jobs and the UK energy security
we need oil and gas jobs so when the
current fuels in the North Sea are
depleted in Scotland's oil and gas
shorts evaporate what will you tell our
members working in these sectors in the
communities which will be decimated the
answer suggested a recognition that this
Rift must be repaired I want to be
absolutely clear oil and gas are going
to be part of the mix for decades to
come into the 2050s and what I will
never let happen
is a repeat of what happened in coal
mining
where an industry came to an end and
nobody had planned for the future the
Union's boss had said Labor's proposals
to strangle the industry were naive now
he thinks their position could shift we
want to work together to manage the
inevitable decline of North Sea oil and
gas we want to do this in a way that's
good for the environment that's good for
the economy that's good for jobs and is
good for National Security there is more
that unites us and divides Us in terms
of our relationship with the labor party
and I think you've seen that on hold
today and kissed armor is persuadable on
this I I hope so uh Luke good leaders
listen and I hope Kirsten is listening
an added challenge in all this is the
fact labor has received millions in
donations both from the GMB Union and
from businessman Dale Vince a Big
Thunder of just stop oil although party
sources insist these donors have no
influence on their policies there'll be
further details on Labor's energy plans
later this month but kirstama knows
striking a balance between economic and
environmental factors was never going to
be easy Making Waves always leaves
someone in a spin Joe Pike Sky News
Brighton